estábamos en este problema de números
complejos y en el vídeo pasado ya vimos
que la opción a es correcta pero puede
ser que otras también lo sean porque así
es este examen el pj bueno entonces
vamos a analizar qué le sucede a la b c
y d empecemos con la b ahora si nos
piden cosas acerca del argumento déjame
copiarla por acá la b dice que el
argumento argumento de z menos z 1 es
igual al argumento argumento de zeta
menos z 2 y tenemos que determinar si
esto es verdadero o es falso muy bien lo
que voy a hacer es reciclar un poco del
álgebra que ya teníamos desde el vídeo
pasado entonces en vez de poner
argumento de zeta menos z 1 voy a
cambiar z menos z 1 por esta expresión
que desarrollamos o sea t x z 2 - z 1
muy bien entonces lo voy a poner aquí
abajito entonces en vez de tener
argumentos de zeta 2 - eta 1 tenemos
argumento de t x zeta 2 menos zeta
vale ahí está ok y la pregunta es si
esto es igual es igual al argumento
argumento y de manera similar vamos a
reciclar el álgebra tenemos z menos z 2
z menos z 2 vimos que era uno menos t x
z1 menos z 2 entonces voy a poner esta
expresión
1 - t
voy a ponerlo con paréntesis 1 de x z 1
menos z 2 ahora a lo mejor es un poco
difícil de cumplir de comparar los
argumentos de estos dos números
complejos entonces la idea es poner a
este de la derecha como un múltiplo de z
2 - z 1 o sea cambiar el signo aquí
porque aquí también tenemos z 2 - z 1
entonces bueno esta igualdad se da
siempre y cuando se dé la igualdad con
el argumento de imira para cambiar el
signo aquí sin que se afecte la
expresión también le voy a cambiar el
signo a esto es como multiplicar por
menos uno y otra vez por menos uno que
no hace ningún efecto entonces aquí
quédate menos uno cambiando del signo al
primero x z 2 menos zeta
muy bien entonces la primera igualdad de
cierta siempre y cuando se dé la
igualdad entre este y este pero éstas ya
las podemos estudiar fácilmente haciendo
un dibujo de un plano complejo déjame
hacer eso déjame pintar por acá la parte
el eje el eje imaginario por acá voy a
pintar el eje real el eje real y aunque
no sepamos dónde está z 2 - eta 1 déjame
pintarlo por ahí en algún lugar entonces
pensamos que por aquí queda z 2 - z 1
entonces pregunta dónde queda t por z 2
1 déjame pintar aquí esta línea para
indicar el vector que va hacia el número
complejo entonces la pregunta es dónde
quedaría t por z 2 - eta 1 pues observa
de lo que sabemos de t es que este mayor
que 0 y que te es menor que 1 entonces
al escalar un número por un factor que
está entre 0 y 1 obtenemos un número que
queda entre el origen y ese número
complejo entonces queda sobre esta línea
déjame déjame tomar el color verde para
pintarlo entonces por aquí en algún
lugar
digamos digamos que te es como dos
tercios entonces por aquí quédate
multiplicado
x z 2 - setup 1 vale ok entonces aquí
tenemos el argumento que nos interesa
este aquí este si es igual a el
argumento de t por z 2 - z 1 pero ahora
dónde queda dónde queda el número
complejo z 2 - z 1 x t menos 1 entonces
deja de tomar este color o sea sabemos
que t
además de ser mayor que 0 es menor que 1
por lo tanto te menos 1 este numerito de
acá es negativo le voy a poner aquí
negativo que sucede entonces pues que
estamos multiplicando z 2 - z 1 por un
número negativo y por lo tanto se voltea
con respecto al origen ahora va a
apuntar hacia allá déjame tomar el color
verde no el color morado y entonces por
lo tanto te -1 por z 2 - z 1 ahora es un
número que va hacia allá y por lo tanto
su argumento ahora es este ángulo de acá
verdad y este ángulo definitivamente es
distinto de fin de hecho es fi más
maspyme parece sin más pi
entonces bueno acá tenemos si más o
menos pi como quieras pensar
pero el chiste es que el argumento y el
argumento es distinto vale entonces
estar acá la opción b es que es inválida
déjame tachar la aquí arriba entonces la
opción de la opción b no se vale estar
acá es falsa podríamos seguir con el pse
pero el d se parece mucho al vez
entonces ya que estamos con estas ideas
déjame hacer el de entonces el de el
inciso de dice que el argumento
argumento de zeta menos z1 zeta menos z1
es igual al argumento de zeta 2 menos z1
destetados menos zeta una misma idea
vamos a reciclar el álgebra que tenemos
de este lado tenemos el argumento el
argumento de t por zeta 2 - z 1 y de
este lado queremos ver el argumento de
zeta 2 - se está aún entonces podríamos
dibujar otro plano complejo no de hecho
sabes que creo que sería mejor idea
reciclar este que ya tenemos
hemos reciclado mucho en este problema
entonces reciclando esto pues mira aquí
tenemos esta 2 - z uno que es el del
lado derecho y ya tenemos este por z 2 -
z 1 y el argumento de zeta 2 - z 1 pues
también es este ángulo y este ángulo y
este ángulo son iguales y por lo tanto
la igualdad de si se cumple el inciso d
es verdadero entonces déjame subir de
circular este y vamos a ponerle palomita
de que también es verdadero bueno para
que el vídeo no me quede muy largo
déjame dejar el inciso c para el
siguiente vídeo entonces hasta ahorita
llevamos que a y de son verdaderos pero
ve no lo es nos vemos hasta la próxima